[Musique]
bonjour à tous
un dimanche de sport sur france 3
franche comté vous retrouverez le trade
efforts de besançon un peu avant 13h sur
votre chaîne régionale nous allons ici
continuer à parler de sport et plus
particulièrement de la politique
sportive de nos collectivités ont-elles
encore les moyens de leurs ambitions en
la matière contraints de se tourner vers
le privé les clubs nos clubs il trouve
t-il leurs intérêts entre le sport
d'élite et le sport pour tous faut-il
choisir on va poser ses questions à nos
quatre invités je vous les présente
d'abord abdel ghezali vous êtes adjoint
socialiste à la ville de besançon en
charge des sports également sur ce
plateau christophe rault pied vice
président en charge des sports également
membre du parti des républicains en
charge des sports à l'agglomération de
montbéliard
aux côtés de ces deux élus locaux deux
responsables de clubs d'abord sylvain
chalot président du cc etupes l'un des
meilleurs clubs cyclistes amateurs de
france et raphaëlle tervelle entraîneuse
de l'esb f entre et nous vous y tenez le
sbf qui est je le rappelle le seul club
de sport collectif
la seule équipe de sport collectif a
évolué au niveau élite en franche-comté
bonjour à tous les quatre merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors je vous
rappelle que vous aussi devant votre
téléviseur vous pouvez commenter
l'émission y participer commentez
l'émission sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le modeste qui s'affiche dit mme paul fc
comme dimanche en politique franche
comté et puis je me ferais le relais de
quelques unes de vos questions tout au
long de ce débat alors madame messieurs
il n'y a plus d'argent dans les caisses
c'est ce qu'on entend nos élus locaux ne
cessent de le répéter justifiant ici la
limitation des subventions là la baisse
carrément des aides publiques
alors la culture et le sport dit on
seraient sacrifiés sur l'autel des
contraintes de budget adèle ghezzal y
est vous qui êtes adjoint aux sports à
besançon le sport est-il aujourd'hui la
variable d'ajustement
des budgets locaux et on sait que
l'ajustement aujourd'hui se fait plutôt
à la baisse
oui pas d'une manière générale il ya une
raréfaction de l'argent public c'est un
fait néanmoins pour une collectivité
pour la ville que nous sommes le sport
et la culture reste des éléments forts
d'une politique municipale et donc on
arrive toujours dans des difficultés
puisque il faut aussi faire des choix
néanmoins le sport à besançon n'a pas
été une variable d'ajustement
mais les budget sports de la ville ils
sont orientés comment ah ben il n'y a
pas eu de baisse des subventions aux
associations en ce qui concerne le sport
pendant ce mandat est ce que c'est la
même chose christophe rault pied dans
l'agglomération de montbéliard
oui alors pas de baisse au niveau des
subventions liées au sport et au même on
je vais vous dire on s'est rajouté des
fonds quand il faut puisque les
dernières on sait que sur le pays de
montbéliard honneur on a donc organisé
une poule préliminaire de l'euro féminin
de handball et donc on a su ajouter 100
mille euros sur notre ligne au sport
pour pouvoir aller chercher cet
événement donc toutes les plaintes qu'on
peut entendre des milieux associatifs
sportifs et culturels elles sont vaines
ce sont des menteurs les responsables
d'associations qui disons nous baisse
nos subventions régulièrement
non il n'ya pas de on travaille avec les
associations
on essaye de monter les budgets avec
elle néanmoins et c'est légitime on y
viendra certainement dans le débat mais
quand on a des ambitions puisque c'est
le titre de votre de votre émission
il y a une volonté de passer un cap et
peut-être qu'à ce moment là on a des
attentes qui ne sont pas on ne répond
pas à toutes les attentes
néanmoins si on parle de budget global
il n'y a pas eu de baisse
néanmoins des associations peuvent nous
solliciter de manière plus grande plus
forte ce qui peut être légitime
en terme d'ambition est simplement on en
reparlera mais nous on a ce qu'on
appelle des contrats d'objectifs pour
pour travailler sur ces avec ces
associations
sylvain chalot quand on gère justement
une association sportive est ce qu'on
les intègre ces contraintes budgétaires
collectivités locales tout à fait on est
on est complètement obligé de prévoir
notre subvention annuelle à peu près
l'imaginé déjà parce qu'on va la dépense
et au cours de l'année elles doivent
tomber en fin d'année par rapport à
budget et surtout une assemblée générale
qui a rendu des comptes d'une année est
ce qu'on a mais utiliser cet argent
donc oui on est obligé d'un objet de
planifier notre budget sur l'année c'est
la même problématique pour tous pour
tous les clubs
les contraintes j à cancon mes confrères
ou mes amis autres présidents de clubs
disent ça baisse il ya plusieurs ya
plusieurs cas il ya des associations qui
font moins d'efforts dans le donnant
donnant maintenant je pense que les
collectivités attendre beaucoup plus de
rendu les clubs ne me voilà sa
subvention il faut qu'il y ait un retour
mais par contre ça fait plus de travail
et comme nous cc etupes on a la grande
chance d'avoir cette subvention qui se
maintient on nous le dit partout mais
effectivement comment comment continuer
à vivre depuis 5 8 ans avec des
subventions qui se maintiennent une
grande chance il faut s'organiser nous
on a on a réduit notre groupe on cherche
d'autres partenaires privés on cherche
d'autres solutions pour a pour compléter
un petit peu tu as donné que les
dépenses l'autoroute les sens et c'est
pour nous notre sport un coût de plus en
plus cher on cherche on cherche d'autres
solutions pour pour un voilà pour finir
finir nos budgets correctement et c'est
bien à une impérative afin le terme elle
le sbf 120 sbf120 la ville sont les
aides de la ville de bezons non
franchement non nous remercie vraiment
les collectivités parce qu'on est
vraiment soutenu par toutes les
collectivités donc ça c'est ça c'est
super depuis depuis des années
nous on veut passer un cap mais on a
bien compris que c'était pas auprès des
collectivités qu'on franchit rescap donc
voilà on a mis en place un nouveau
projet pour essayer d'aller d'aller
chercher des partenaires alors locaux
certes mais aussi et surtout nationaux
ce qui nous manque un autre échelle pour
décoller un peu ce serait un ou deux
partenaires partenaires nationaux quoi
aujourd'hui le l'argent est
indispensable à la réussite sportive
malheureusement oui alors même si on a
tendance à prouver le contraire ces
dernières années parce qu'on fait partie
des plus petits budgets en finir l'année
dernière sur le podium du championnat
c'est juste pas normal
c'est un petit miracle mais les miracles
ça dure pas et nous on a envie de
pérenniser le club on n'a pas envie
qu'on a envie de plus on n'a plus envie
de rester parmi les meilleurs on a envie
d'être les meilleurs et si on veut
franchir cette petite marche qui nous
manque forcément il nous manque encore
un petit peu de un petit peu d'argent
pour pour ce pouvoir se renforcer et
puis allez aller titiller les grosses
équipes
ce que vous nous dites et l'un et
l'autre c'est qu'aujourd'hui finalement
le recours au privé est indispensable
qu'est ce que vous leur vendée comment
va chercher des chefs d'entreprise de du
mécénat finalement le mécénat nous c'est
facile à on a un budget moitié
subventions des collectivités moitié de
subventions et de dotation privée donc
l'un apporte l'autre aussi étant donné
que on a en a payé maquis à 20% de notre
et montbéliard agglomération opération
bien sûr pardon qui sont à 20% de notre
notre budget le doubs 15%
on à étupes 9% pour les toutes petites
communes cc formidable et on à la région
qui termine avec 5 % mais voilà cet
accompagnement là nous donne une image
donne une visibilité et nous permet en
plus des résultats sportifs et bien de
se promouvoir
et il faut un petit peu on si vous
regardez le bal la marque sur le maillot
vous le revendez exactement ce qu'ils de
ce don était exposée par le sdf c'est
c'est le côté marc maintenant les clubs
doivent se démarquer
on doit montrer on doit donner de la
visibilité alors ça peut être beaucoup
de solutions nous dans le vélo c'est
beaucoup plus dur on n'a pas de stade
pour réunir les partenaires privés par
contre on participe à tout ce qui est
club affaire daniel jack isaac sur sur
belfort montbéliard on on reçoit
énormément sur les réseaux sociaux
et finalement voilà on parle beaucoup de
ça on
on vend cette pub 5000 personnes sur des
réseaux sociaux 20000 vu sur un autre
site etc et on met on met en lumière nos
partenaires pour pas donner de l'argent
simplement que ça devienne pas une
dotation avec ce soir à donnant donnant
alors un donnant donnant aussi pour les
collectivités
christophe rault pied vous pour
subventionner un club comme le cc etupes
vous demandez quoi en retour il il faut
offrir un retour notamment en image
aussi aux collectivités
oui alors l'exemple du cc etupes e
particulier parce qu'on sylvain le cdh 1
puis vous le dira mieux que moi c'est
pas seulement des subventions ou du
public ou du privé c'est aussi une vie
autour du club du cc etupes 1 se situe
peu capable dans le même mois
d'organiser une course une course
cycliste organisée une soirée de gala
est de faire un loto le lendemain je
crois qu'il ya une belle dynamique sur
ce social voilà si la subvention elle
correspond aussi à ça vous organisez pas
la subvention publiquement tous les cas
la vie du club est importante aussi
parler d'ambitions tout à l'heure on
pourrait avoir beaucoup d'argent tout
l'argent nécessaire site en face de vous
vous n'avez pas un club qui a envie un
comité qui s'est organisé des
manifestations ou créer une dynamique
autour d'un club
finalement l'argent ne suffit pas on le
voit avec les clubs qu'on accompagne
aujourd'hui ses accès à tous c'est aussi
bien
une ambition politique de soutenir un
événement ou un club mais aussi une
ambition du club et de son comité de
pouvoir clés de la vie et du vivre
ensemble autour de autour du club
une question christian lorsqu'on
constate qu'une ville comme besançon
fait évoluer son club de basket qui est
en nationale 1 dans un petit gymnase de
quartier alors qu'un magnifique palais
des sports a été rénové sous la même
municipalité du regretté robert schwint
il ya effectivement de quoi s'interroger
sur les ambitions de la ville d'al
ghazaya je me tourne forcément vers vous
c'est un reproche qu'on vous fait très
souvent je le sais que répondre ou aux
autres parce que le votre ville et
l'agglomération a fait le pari du
handball très clairement oui enfin la
ville a fait le pari du handball à ce
niveau-là néanmoins je le redis quand on
parle du basket et qui est le buzz ac
qui est un bon club de basket qui évolue
en nationale 1 on a
sbf qui évolue en élite en d1 donc c'est
un choix assumé par la municipalité
mais qui veut pas dire quand on évolue
au gymnase des montboucons au gymnase
des montboucons quelques uns des
basketteurs jeu pour les noms bisontins
se précise voilà oui voilà pour le pour
le buzz ac
néanmoins ce qu'on peut dire parce qu'il
faut qu'on se dise aussi les choses
ce qu'on peut se dire c'est que en lien
et l'agglomération de l'agglomération du
grand besançon prend de plus en plus sa
place
elle n'a pas la même histoire que que
pays de montbéliard mais elle prend de
plus en plus sa place
il ya eu la pose de la première pierre
du stade d' escalade et on sait qu'à
terme ça sera l'agglo qui portera le
sport de haut niveau en termes de
rayonnement et qui portera aussi les
grands équipements donc on manque à
besançon certainement deux gymnases
néanmoins on a fait le choix et on dit
souvent que les élus ne choisissent pas
ne font pas les choix qu'il faut on a
fait le choix de besançon terre de hand
et on assume le fait de faire évoluer en
tout cas à partir du moment où le club
évolue en d1 est qui et qui a été
européens ont fait le choix mais on ne
néglige pas le basket puisque le basket
évolue aussi au gymnase des montboucons
raphaëlle tervelle c'est aussi un
avantage pour le sbf d'être désormais le
seul club d'élite sur la place oui
certaines vous l'avez pas choisi un jeu
tout le monde voilà mai mais le fait est
que c'est comme ça du coup il y avait
les autres mais oui c'est vrai après ça
se ressent aussi en terme d'affluence je
pense parce que sur cette année on a
rempli le palais à chaque fois entre
2000 et 3000 et 3000 personnes sur sur
quasiment tous les matches et c'est même
c'est même mieux qu'un autre époque à
l'époque où
c'était effectivement on remplissait le
palais y avait 3000 personnes à chaque
fois qu'on joue en coupe d'europe mais
en championnat il n'y avait pas grand
monde coire et en fait on se rend compte
que cette année il ya un vrai engouement
derrière notre équipe qu'elle met alors
en 2003 et c'est pas la préhistoire 2003
il ya 15 ans enfin 16 ans il y avait du
foot en lice deuil avait dû aucun en
élite j'avais du basket hand élite
il y avait une vraie concurrence
sportive sur besançon ça il y avait un
je me rappelle ont en partage et le
palais des sports avec le basket
d'ailleurs alors par rapport à ça il y
avait quand même une petite règle qui a
changé c'est que nous maintenant on est
obligé de jouer sur un taraflex sur un
sol
mou alors que le basket ne peut jouer
que sur du parquet donc il ya juste une
incompatibilité aussi à faire cohabiter
les deux sports dans la même salle
vous avez présenté vous l'avez évoqué
rapidement tout à l'heure un en début de
semaine un nouveau projet pour les 10 15
ans qui viennent avec un message clair
pour être identifiés pour vendre une
marque finalement aujourd'hui il faut
faire ça pour aller chercher des
nouveaux financements des partenaires
nationaux y très clairement jusqu'à
maintenant on n'avait pas grand chose à
vendre et là on a vraiment maintenant
une image une image à vendre on veut
vraiment s'engager sur sur ces aspects
de d'égalité et puis sur le message
aussi que nos joueuses sont des femmes
sportives et que voilà on a envie que
qu'elle soit aussi des exemples pour
pour les autres pour les petites filles
et puis pourra pourquoi là pour que tout
le monde puisse voir que tout est
possible que le rêve de chacune peut se
réaliser
et pour ça il faut qu'il faut que faut
que les enfants et des exemples filles
ou garçons donc c'est important
alors j'étais à cette conférence de
presse il ya un chiffre qui m'a marqué
c'est qu'il ya une seule joueuse de
votre équipe
on le rappelle troisième du championnat
l'an passé qui touche un salaire
supérieur à la moyenne des salaires de
la première division féminine
ça veut dire que on bricole à besançon
cas qu'on aura les moyens de bien
rémunérer les les joueuses forcément on
bricole pas je dirais pas ça je dirais
qu'on optimise tout on optimise nos
moyens ça c'est ça c'est sûr après
l'objectif aussi pour pour nous c'est
justement là on a un très bon niveau
sportif et on voudrait ma structure est
un peu notre notre extra sportives pour
qu'on rattrape un peu ce retard est
effectivement l'apport de grégory et
hervelle comme manager fait beaucoup
pour pour sa veuve beaucoup dans ce sens
là et l'apport d'un statut aussi sur le
projet qui est mis en place
c'est on a besoin de gens compétents et
les astres à prendre un petit peu de
temps encore mais je pense qu'on est sur
la bonne voie pour essayer de faire
décoller et vous avez dit ce projet d'un
envie de rester
on a on a parlé de d'éventuels départs
en tout cas de soucis de sollicitations
dont vous avez fait l'objet l'an passé
là vous êtes à besançon pour quelques
années
si on arrive à décoller c'est toujours
pas et bien sûr on y croit on y croit
mais mais oui vu aujourd'hui on n'a pas
les moyens de nos ambitions nous qu'on
espère que ce projet là fera que oui si
tout va bien nous aussi on est bien ici
et on reste sylvain chalot il ya une
concurrence entre les clubs concluent
aussi bien en haut niveau des
collectivités pour les subventions qu'au
niveau des entreprises
non je dirais pas ça parce qu'on n'a pas
le un club qui descend un ça donne pas
forcément plus d'argent aux clubs
voisins et le malheur des uns ne fait
pas le bonheur des autres et on essaie
de ne pas regarder un petit peu les
autres clubs ce qu'ils peuvent avoir en
subventions etc
chaque sport est tellement différent on
essaye nous un petit peu main d'oeuvre
et pour notre lot de paroisses et on
essaye de défendre nos projets dans wii
on peut pas il ya l'argent il n'est pas
un indéfinie la concurrence elle se fera
dans les dossiers elle se fera dans la
com dans et renseigner sur les nouveaux
projets qui sont
qui sont possibles d'être éligible pour
le club et c'est ça va être fait à
l'affût faut être à l'affût et vous par
exemple le côté
onfray d'autre voie de développement fo
comme un club c'est vraiment une petite
entreprise gros clubs deviennent des
entreprises on doit les structures et
est toujours là comme la comme la com
pour à pourvoir mettre en avant nos
partenaires mettre en avant l'équipe les
résultats et puis qu'on parle de nous
toujours adèle guizani en tant qu'élu
local vous considérer qu'une ville peut
rayonner par ses équipes sportives
est-ce qu on rayonne encore par le sport
enfin c'est pas est-ce qu'on peut
rayonner une équipe sportive fait
rayonner une ville fait rayonner une
agglo un département une région
je pense que ce qui permet cela c'est
une complémentarité
moi je n'oublie pas qu'en tant qu'élu
local mon rôle aussi c'est d'accompagner
ce qu'on appelle le sport amateur
je ne pourrais jamais le sport amateur
au sport de sport d'élite sport pour
tous oui mais si on prend l'exemple et
récurrentes oui mais si on prend
l'exemple de le sbf faut pas oublier
qu'à la vitrine la partie visible mais à
le sbf il ya plein de gamine qui sont là
et est reconnu en tant que formateur
donc ce qui est important pour nous
c'est notre compétence fait qu'on doit
or c'est normal chacun est dans son rôle
mais nous on doit aussi accompagner moi
je suis fier qu'on puisse continuer à
accompagner c'est pas péjoratif mais des
petites associations besoin de vivre
mais bien sûr qu'une ville mais une
ville pas seulement vous avez parlé du
partenariat privé une ville avec son
agglo avec son département avec sa
région peut faire rayonner parce que
quand on parle du handball du foot où on
parle de montbéliard on parle de
besançon et je pense qu'on fait rayonner
des villes
christophe rault pied dans le pays de
montbéliard est l'équipe qui rayonne
plus ou moins c'est le fc sochaux est ce
que vous subissez ce qui se passe
actuellement au club en tant qu'élu
local pourtant vous êtes partenaires de
premier plan puisque le le stade il
appartient il appartient à l'agglo
comment on gère ça en tant qu'élu local
cette situation la gère on gère
difficilement on a déjà subi on la subit
et c'est vrai que ça fait quatre ans
aujourd'hui qu'on était venu d'ailleurs
sur ce plateau on parle et je croyais un
peu moins de deux ans on souhaitait déjà
le départ de l'actionnaire principal
wings ont glee était trop ça y est il
est parti voilà en tout cas wings ont
glissé de pro et est encore là et c'est
vrai que aujourd'hui on a deux leviers
au niveau de l'agglomération se baisser
les subventions et ne plus louer le
stade en tout cas mettre le stade à
disposition du club je crois que c'est
de levier la hong hong et on ne peut pas
imaginer les utiliser simplement je
crois que c'est un peu l'objet du coup
de gueule que j'ai passé dans l'équipe
il ya quinze jours c'est se dire
aujourd'hui comment on peut laisser un
club comme le fc sochaux sur la touche
mourir alors que on le sait très bien
on a un rôle nous en tant qu'élu
d'animer notre territoire est de
promouvoir en tout cas notre territoire
et le fc sochaux quand vous êtes en
france ou même en europe ou encore plus
loin on reconnaît notre territoire grâce
au fc sochaux grâce à son histoire
sportive et donc on sait situer le pays
de montbéliard grâce au fc sochaux donc
c'est clair que cette situation là elle
peut plus durer
on sait que sportivement ça va se jouer
le 17 mai en tous les cas on espère que
le puisse se maintenir
et voilà c'est compliqué pour pour l'élu
que je suis julien vous dit la question
capitale aujourd'hui c'est l'avenir du
fcsm annuellement c'est une somme
considérable alloués au stade est ce que
vous le chiffre et ça parce que c'est
pas de ça sort pas des caisses de
l'agglomération mais c'est dû c'est du
factuel coffre oui alors il ya plusieurs
conventions 1 qui existe avec le fc
sochaux notamment celle de mise à
disposition du stade mais en un loyer en
fasquelle lors de 390 mille euros qui
est payé par le club je le dis payé
puisqu'on nous a souvent demandé si le
fc sochaux payait son loyer
le fc sochaux paye son loyer à la mais
pour revenir sur notre politique
sportive vous parliez notre politique
sportive en tout cas de notre ambition
aujourd'hui je crois qu au niveau de
l'agglomération du pays de montbéliard
on joue le jeu avec les clubs ont parlé
d'animation d'attractivité quand vous
accompagner un championnat d'europe de
handball
vous jouez le jeu pour le club du pays
de montbéliard pour un événement pour
son rayonnement
mais aussi pour le sbf parce qu on est
dans un cadre développement d'un sport
et on a envie aussi
je crois qu'on s'est rencontrés
régulièrement à avec le club dont on
s'est vu on a travaillé ensemble c'est
vraiment aussi la dimension régionale de
le sbf tout à fait ce qui pourrait nous
amener à terme à venir
aussi créer un partenariat avec le club
parce qu'on a une belle dynamique
handball sur le pays de montbéliard
on est on avec le mans en nationale 2
c'est vrai que pourquoi pas travailler
avec le sbf et c'est cette dimension là
qu'il faut prendre aujourd'hui on compte
sur nos territoires et je crois que
voilà on a plusieurs exemples parler de
vélo tout à l'heure quand vous parlez
cyclo-cross aujourd'hui besançon le fait
bien
avec le club bisontin on a un club sur
le pays de montbéliard qui nous fait
rayonner lors des coupes du monde
en janvier on aura une coupe du monde
c'est neuf millions de personnes qui
sont touchées
donc autant vous dire que le la base de
brognard le cyclo cross de nos mais on
connaît pas seulement en bourgogne
franche comté
donc voilà c'est tout l'essence même de
notre de notre mandat d'élu 7 pouvoir
accompagner des clubs qui ont envie et
si les clubs ont envie si l'organisation
est dynamique
charge à nous de pouvoir faire notre
maximum pour financièrement les suivre
comment les clubs du pays de montbéliard
voilà la situation du fc sochaux parce
que forcément c'est un peu une
locomotive sportive en tout cas dans
l'image du sport est-ce qu'on vous en
parle on en parle aussi sur le bord des
routes lors des courses cyclistes est ce
que ça touche vraiment les gens dans le
pays de montbéliard
oui tout à fait tout le monde en parle
nous on est le cse mis son partenaire du
club il nous aide et nous accompagne
donc forcément c'est des amis en dehors
de ça le système reste le gros clubs
sportifs de la région lors l'ordre de
regarder pas déplu en élite
effectivement là le seul club en élite
le voilà alors c'est le sb mais les voir
descendre ça resterait une catastrophe
sportive ce stade deviendrait un peu une
friche sportive et sa souhaiter à
personne et si le fcsm fonctionnaires
tourne vraiment au plus haut niveau
c'est également pour nous l'occasion de
se positionner d'aller rencontrer leurs
partenaires de leur offrir encore une
autre publicité donc nous aussi on
profitera en profitera de sa et voilà
c'est c'est l'image d'une image d'une
région c'est emblématique quand j'étais
petit on me disait tu viens d'où de ce
show là tu connais et le stade de foot
meoli gens parlent du club de football
que de lusine vient également quasiment
bien sûr mais c'est voilà c'est ça situe
un petit peu une région sur un sur la
carte tout le reste est une région la
déléguée a lyon on a parlé des
événements internationaux à l'axone
besançon se positionne aussi régulière
par exemple pour accueillir le tour de
france ou pour accueillir l'équipe de
foot féminine la sélection nationale
est-ce qu'il ya aussi faute peut-être
faute de mieux
sans faire injure à le sbf mais faute de
sport co de foot en ligue 1 2 voilà une
politique événementielle vous misez sur
des événements pour aussi proposer à vos
habitants du haut niveau oui bien sûr
mais ça c'est propre à toute
collectivité c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression que ça se développe qu'il
ya un déclic le nom on le développe
parce que pour plusieurs raisons il faut
dire qu'aujourd'hui des fédérations sont
de plus en plus exigeante et des
collectivités tic avant de pouvoir aller
parce que les tickets d'entrée sont
souvent très très lourd très cher et
nous la force de la ville de besançon
c'est nos services avec les
infrastructures mais nos services et on
sait répondre rapidement
on se rappelle quand même et ça c'est
propre aussi aux autres collectivités
c'est que quand on est dans le sport on
parle souvent des fonctionnaires les
gens sont là le matin sont là le soir
sont là le week-end ils donnent de leur
temps et c'est ça aussi qui est reconnue
à besançon sert qu'au delà de l'argent
vous donner du matériel logistique c'est
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
l'important c'est l'accompagnement
évidemment la subvention c'est quelque
chose d'important d'essentiel mais
surtout quand on se tourne vers les
collectivités c'est de nous dire est ce
que peuvent accueillir les barrières est
ce que vous pouvez travailler on
travaille bien avec l'amicale cycliste
et a besoin tiens aussi à dire à rendre
aussi hommage mais à tous les bénévoles
dans ces associations qui travaillent
mais au niveau des collectivités on a
accueilli en 2004 2009 2012 2014 le tour
de france on accueilli il y à il ya deux
mois de ça même pas de match de futsal
entre la france et l'angleterre ont fait
le championnat de france de cyclo-cross
donc on arrive à répondre et je pense
que c'est des événements qui sont qui
rassemble au delà des pratiques des uns
et des autres les événements sportifs
nationaux rassemble aussi rassemble
aussi une ville et ça c'est important
pour nous d'y répondre
c'est vrai que souvent les présidents de
clubs mais je comprends pas pour
l'événementiel il ya des nouveaux
budgets
et effectivement les gens doivent
comprendre qu'un qu'un événement comme
ça ça fait rayonner toute une région et
ça attire beaucoup de monde on organise
fin femme et une coupe de france on
espère remplir bien de les hôtels etc
le 30 mai rallonge vlc genre d'événement
qui attire du monde sur une sur notre
région et qui fait marcher tous les tous
les mondes de le monde de l'hôtellerie
restauration est on a coutume de dire
qu'il ya des répercussions après sur les
inscriptions dans les clubs que ça fait
venir les jeunes notamment voilà bien
sûr pour confirmer raphaëlle tervelle
oui bien sûr quand on organise une
compétition en france et encore quand on
a la chance d'avoir une poule pas très
loin de besoins sombre et bien sûr il ya
toujours des nouvelles des nouveaux
licenciés qui arrive tous les ans un
élément on est en plein travail
d'efforts aujourd'hui il faut savoir que
le travail des forces et plus de 5000
inscrits or on parle très rarement de ça
et je pense qu'on est aussi responsable
de la valorisation aussi en terme
économique du sport dans nos villes dans
nos agglo dans nos départements et notre
région
aujourd'hui le trail des forces et plus
de cinq mille cinq cents participants
dans les 5500 je pense qu'elle n'a au
moins
enfin en termes de nuitées en termes de
restauration en termes économiques c'est
quelque chose aussi d'importants je
pense aussi au fcsm à sochaux en termes
économiques c'est quelque chose
d'important il traîne et fort justement
vous le retrouverez sur cette antenne
aux alentours de 12 heures 50 avec
clément jana en attendant dans un
instant c'est le flash d'information en
région puis la suite de dimanche en
politique
francis letellier reçoit ce midi yannick
jadot la tête de liste d'europe écologie
les verts pour les européennes merci de
nous avoir suivis merci à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
[Musique]